in the Basque country the makhila is the
honorary object par excellence
[Music]
the makhila it comes from the mac it has a lot
of bonelli there it's death a tool
for walking but also a tool for
defending
dsk
kenneth s
je m  my name is lisa bergara and i am the
seventh generation of my family to
make maquilas
in adama guèye seck lavaud redhead
stakes
match
so in fact we don't know the
exact origin of the object it's a mystery
however we have writings  we have
iconographic documents from the
19th century
10 ticks arinc friedli au night and day
on earth
hour at
[Music]
we are five people in the workshop so
there is mailly who works leather diaby
who works metal then you have
chemistry  and Frédéric who will take care of
everything that is advanced and then finally me
so lisa
me I take care of the engraving part
[Music]
so we have plans of neef signed which
were planted by my great
grandfather and the  medlar it is this wood which
allows  give maquilas not here here
we are in the attic so that is where
we will store all our wood which
is maturing the wood will wait about
ten years before being brought up to
make a makila
in 2011 we have  been listed on
the unesco crafts inventory our friend
sean
o'brien and mania with the makhila it's
an object that we will pass on in the
family that we never sell so it's
also  that's why we don't have
old makila on the second-hand market,
as I say, we have a working memory,
it's something we cultivate, but
I think it's also something
that isn't  say something that is
felt I too know this passion
that we have and that I hope we manage to
transmit to the people who come to
visit
[Music]
yes